all right let's uh let's talk about
Starship a little bit we've been
sneaking up uh to it and from a bunch of
different directions can you just say
um
what is Starship and what is the most
impressive thing uh to you about it I
mean you've talked about the sort of the
engines involved maybe you haven't
really kind of like dancing around it
but because this is such a crucial
thing in terms of uh the next few years
in terms of your own life personally and
uh also just human civilization reaching
out to the Stars it seems like Starship
is a really important vehicle to making
that happen so what is this thing that
we're talking about yeah so Starship is
uh currently in development the world's
largest most powerful rocket ever built
fully reusable rocket uh two-stage
rocket so the booster is landed and you
know all this is currently aspirational
until it's working uh so I'll I'll say
it's I'll say what it's aspirational
going to be yeah and obviously I have
faith that that will happen but just
factually so the booster will be reused
landed and refueled and reused the upper
stage will be landed refueled and reused
and ideally rapidly in the in the sense
not talking about months or weeks of
refurbishment but literally talking
about like mild inspections and ideally
like under 24 hour reuse you know where
you literally really land it and fly it
like an airplane so it utilizes liquid
methane and liquid oxygen as it's as its
propellants it utilizes the current
iterations of it are 33 Raptor engines
on the booster engine on the booster and
six uh Raptors on the second stage so
there'll be three that are vacuum
optimized and three that are sea level
optimized on the upper stage that are
primarily they'll be used I think at
stage separation anyway in space but um
they'll their main reason that they use
them is so they can use them for landing
too the the three sea level engines to
be able to propulsively land the upper
stage as well so the three wrapped
engines are the ones that generate the
thrust that makes it the most powerful
rocket ever built by a almost double
compared to the Saturn V really the N1
had 45 Mega Newtons of thrust the Saturn
V had I think 35 or 40 Mega names of
thrust and this has 75 Mega Newtons so
we're talking almost double
it's uh it's a lot of power
um that could be the sexiest thing I've
ever heard okay uh so uh so what are the
different testing that's happening so
like uh uh what's a static fire with
some of these raptors look like and
where do we stand you were you're just
talking about offline like the thing
that happened uh yesterday it was
impressive you know everything in this
is kind of iterations and so
um you know the Milestones that we're
seeing we actually have on
everydayastronaut.com we have a
milestone checklist of like all the
things we're hoping to see that we kind
of need to see before the first orbital
flight of this rocket so um a big
milestone that got checked off yesterday
was a wet dress rehearsal so it's
literally like fueling the rocket up
getting ready to do everything but
lighting the engines basically so we're
talking about loading it with propellant
all the way uh this is the first time
yep right there where's the Milestones
right there at the top click that big
picture yep just anywhere that big
picture yep so the there's the what
dress rehearsal so what what's the what
dress rehearsal yep so that's where they
uh for the first time they filled it
completely to the brim with both liquid
oxygen and liquid methane now they've
done component level testing where they
fill it with liquid nitrogen which is
you know it's an inert gas so it's not
like say it leaks out it's not going to
explode uh you can just have a big giant
pool of liquid nitrogen like flooding
the area but it's not going to be an
explosion so they've done that for cryo
testing to make sure all the components
and stuff can handle you know being at
cryogenic temperatures it's kind of a
good analog before you start putting
your your fuel in your oxidizer in there
but now as of uh yesterday they fully
fueled the rocket with uh propellant
both stages the first stage and the
second stage wall fully stacked on the
on the pad like basically I mean it was
the first sense we really got of like
this is what it's going to look like
right before it takes off you know kind
of breathing coming to life for the
first time what does the pad look like
so there's a few interesting aspects of
this what's up with the Chopsticks and
the uh all of that yeah so the the
launch pad is is is unique I've never
seen anything like it um and the prior
history of of space flight but it's a
really simple launch stand they
basically have like this almost looks
like a stool like a you know like a
milking a cow stool thing with a whole a
big giant wow I know you're from Iowa
but yeah
yes we all know what that's doing oh
yeah we all been sitting on that stool
milking cow yeah uh
with a giant hole in the middle and that
hole in the middle of that stool is
where the rocket sits and it sits on
these you know launch clamps
um and then next to it is the so that's
the orbital launch Mount and then next
to it they are the olm some people say
next to it is the orbital launch Tower
or the Olt and that is not only
um integral to fueling up the upper
stage and the upper stage has to have
propellant lines run to it so that they
can fill it with propellant and you know
all that but it also uh they ended up
making it so instead of having a big
crane on site to stack the two on top of
each other they literally just use that
Tower as a crane so the crane has these
giant arms lovingly called the
Chopsticks or the whole system can be
called mechazilla and that will grab
onto first it'll grab onto the booster
pick it up off of its off of its
transporter that transports it from the
production site lifts it up puts it down
onto the launch Mount and then it will
pick up the second stage or the upper
stage Starship and plop it down on top
of the booster and and they did that for
the first time last year actually I
think it was like Valentine's last year
was the first time they used the
Chopsticks to stack it and now they're
doing it quite frequently you know but
ultimately those Chopsticks have to
serve a second purpose they're actually
going to utilize if you say catch it's
not so much they're going to catch the
booster with these Chopsticks it's not
like it's you know a dad trying to catch
a falling child you know it's more that
the the booster and the Starship will
someday land on those arms yeah so
um they're more or less stationary I'm
sure there's some bit of you know
adjustment that the arms will do but
more or less the Rocket's going to
propulsively land and get picked up by
like what's essentially like two
like relatively small ball joints that
hold the entire thing and so has to land
very precisely on these these mountains
then on onto the the launch Mount and
that's what's going to just place it
back onto the stand and allow it to be
refueled and
fly again what's the idea of using the
arms versus having uh launch pad to land
on what's what's the benefit you are
basically moving the mass of what would
be heavy Landing legs and you're putting
kind of that Landing infrastructure onto
a ground system so you're not having to
carry those Landing legs into orbit but
it's also elevated off the ground is
there some aspect to that where you
don't have to balance the thrust and all
the
you can negate some of those like
there's like plume plume interactions
there's like you know the exhaust
hitting concrete and especially with a
rocket this big it's gonna you know use
like three Raptor engines firing if you
know if you have them firing really
close to the ground you're just gonna
absolutely destroy and crater the ground
and you're gonna have to refurbish the
the ground and the landing pad every
time and you know or have huge Landing
legs that are super long and and tall
you know to make it so it's it's
elevated enough to not do that
um so yeah you're kind of you're
avoiding that whole mess by by catching
it high enough off the ground that you
don't have to factor that in and it's
that's how many engines are involved in
the landing as far as the three Raptor
engines well we haven't actually you
know we haven't today seen the exact
Landing sequence so it might be
something like at first they might light
up you know seven or something or nine
or something some number to to
accelerate quickly or decelerate quickly
without the same thing
um and and then shut it down to three or
something for a little bit more granular
control because unlike Falcon 9 Starship
has enough engines and variability to
actually if it needed to hover you know
to maybe more precisely align itself
with the pad it would have that
capability and especially having
multiple engines you know if you only
have a single engine running you can't
really roll You Know Your Role axis you
can do pitch and yaw because the the
engine is kind of like a Rudder it it
can move in two axes so you can easily
pitch and yaw the vehicle but to
actually use Roll Along its vertical
axis you you would either need like
auxiliary engines to roll it or you'd
need a pair of engines so they can be
opposed and induce rolls so by having
two or three running they have all three
axes of control that they would need
kind of like a broomstick you know and
uh bouncing a broomstick on your hand
they can just move it over and if they
need to align it to those Landing Nubs
you know on the landing arms and stuff
like that then uh they can do that
uh speaking of pitching yaw the thing uh
so Starship flips on its belly flops
does a interesting kind of maneuver
on the way down to land uh can you
describe that maneuver what's involved
with that yeah so this is definitely a
first I don't think anything's tried
Landing like this before but the idea is
when you're falling through the
atmosphere the atmosphere could actually
do a lot of work for you you know you're
moving quickly something is falling from
space there's a lot of energy involved
you have a really good video on this as
well
and uh thank you
um the uh as it's falling you know you
can you let the you want to let the
atmosphere do as much work as it can and
so um if you have a uh unsymmetric you
know it's not a ball that's falling this
is some kind of object with with shape
some you know at one face of it is going
to have more surface area than the other
face so you know in the in the shape of
like a cylinder if you're falling you
know like a soda can if you're falling
top or bottom first it's a certain
amount of surface area if you flip that
on its side you actually have a lot more
surface area so with the same exact
vehicle you can actually have a lot more
drag you can actually slow it down a lot
more using the exact same like same
atmosphere same same vehicle just by
turning at 90 degrees you can slow it
down substantially like three or four
times slower
so that's energy that you don't have to
use anywhere else you don't have to use
an engine to slow you down you don't
have to do anything else so SpaceX
realized okay if we flip this thing on
its side and let it fall like a skydiver
almost you know instead of like pencil
diving into the pool you're belly
flopping
you're maximizing the amount of surface
area that's in the Windstream that's
being slowed down
but obviously like in order to land
especially if you're SpaceX and you know
elon's obsessed with like not having
different parts you know he wants the
best part is no part so if you're going
to land with the engines you might as
well use engines that you've already
have the engines that are you know used
for the other portions of flight so you
kick those on and you use those engines
to actually turn it 90 degrees from
belly flopping to feet first
and that way you can use those same
engines to land and you don't have to
have like auxiliary Landing engines you
don't have to have forces you know even
if you were to land like on its belly
with a separate set of engines Not only
would those engines weigh a lot you know
and be extra complexity etc etc but you
also don't have to make the ship be able
to handle Landing you know like on its
belly as opposed to having the forces be
vertical through it but it's a giant
thing you have to rotate in the air huge
and uh as you also highlight you know
there's liquid fuel slushing around in
the tank so like you can't uh I guess
use that fuel directly after another
kind of fuel like there's just
complexities there yeah that involve uh
plus the actual maneuver is difficult
from the like like what are the
thrusters that actually make that make
all that happen you're you're adding a
lot of
complexity uh not a lot but your
complexity to the maneuver and
possibility where failure Could Happen
uh in order to sort of save in order for
the air to do uh some of the work so
what is some of that complexity just you
can Linger on it you know if you if you
think about what it's going to take to
go from horizontal to Vertical
um this rocket in particular that starts
up has these big flaps
um so it has kind of two nose flaps and
two uh rearward flaps the river flaps
are a lot bigger because the majority of
the the mass the engines and stuff are
in the back of the the vehicle so in
order to kind of be stable and they just
fold themselves inwards like on their
dihedral angle at a dihedra angle in
order to
increase or decrease the drag so you can
control its all three axes of control
while it's falling uh you know on its
belly you can control it that way using
these four different fins so you have
these giant moving surfaces that take
thousands of of horsepower or just
insane amount of torque in order to move
these quickly enough to be a valid
control surface so that's a huge
complication is moving these fins and
developing that that Landing algorithm
and the you know the control for a huge
vehicle with flaps going like you know
in and out in and out in and out to stay
stable then right as you light the
engines now all of a sudden you want the
top you know you want to flip the rocket
90 degrees so the rearward flaps the
bottom flaps fold in they tuck all the
way into minimize drag that's going to
make it want to you know swing down you
extend the upper flaps that makes it so
the nose wants to pitch up you kick on
the engines
um they're now lighting all three
engines at least as of the last like
successful attempts they like all three
of the sea level Raptor engines and
they're pitched all the way like you
know 10 or 15 degrees or whatever the
maximum pitch is on them and that
induces a you know it does that kick
maneuver to kick it over from horizontal
to vertical now the problem is you lit
your engines while you're horizontal so
they put some horizontal velocity into
the rocket they're push the rocket you
know at the time the nose is at the time
of lighting those engines the nose is
facing the Horizon and the engines are
facing the opposite Horizon yeah see now
shot at a decent amount and often you
know the direction that you're not
falling you know
um so you have to factor that in to
where you're Landing because you're
going to land on this precise in this
case you're going to land on the inside
the arm the loving arms of the
Chopsticks you know the Creed Arms Wide
Open you know try to land inside this
exactly the song they're playing through
my head as I watch this now thank you
thank you for forever joining those two
I appreciate this and you have to very
precisely control so what you have to do
is now that it's done that kick you also
have to cancel out that horizontal
velocity so it's actually going to
rotate Beyond 90 degrees to cancel out
that horizontal velocity
and then modulate the engines to make it
so the thrust you know is is perfect
so that it can control itself into a
controlled landing and all this is done
in like 500 meters like 1500 feet you
know you're doing all of those things
stupidly close to the ground it looks
absurd so far they've done five of these
tests
all um the first four all blew up you
know um they're all coming in from about
10 kilometers or 33 000 feet
um falling flipping you know again this
thing is huge that just the booster or
just the upper stage of this
um is is like 50 meters tall you know so
it's 150 well it's like 45 meter about
50 meters tall about 165 feet tall 9
meters wide so 30 feet wide it weighs
you know something like God I don't
remember if it's something like 120
metric tons so 120 000 kilograms you
know two quarter of a million pounds
empty and it's doing this flip maneuver
and it has to do all this perfectly so
the first four four attempts of this
were pretty spectacular failures so just
to clarify which stage is doing this
maneuver it's the upper stage it's doing
this belly flop maneuver yep uh so this
is the the stage that would presumably
um have humans on board if we were to
use
um uh if things continue to plan now
here's here's something I would love to
see yeah just saying this yeah if you
already have these big Arrow surfaces
the flaps they also have to move they're
on heavy Motors and hinges and flaps and
all that stuff I'm actually surprised
that for Earth
they aren't just looking at Landing it
horizontally on a Runway like space
shuttle
oh
I mean interesting that worked the brand
did it you know the Soviet Union's put
on I rolled my arm real hard there sorry
thank you wow wow really good I'm very
impressed very impressed and uh you know
the Branded it do we have other space
planes like the X-37B uh we have the
upcoming Sierra Nevada's Dream Chaser uh
it's yeah you have some extra mass in
the wings but so does Starship Starship
has the extra mass of those flaps and
you know the the motors and the hinges
and all that stuff I I would like to see
the trade on like is it actually lighter
weight
to do that versus doing what SpaceX is
doing
so yeah I mean that's that's the funny
thing I think realistically if Elon
walks in the door tomorrow and says guys
we did some simulations and actually
it's like we can get another 5 000
kilograms into space if we just land it
horizontal if we kind of give up on our
ego and land horizontally at least on
Earth
then you know I think they could be
doing that pretty quickly because that's
the thing is uh this ultimate thing has
been to land on Mars and you know other
planets and Mars doesn't have a Runway
doesn't have a you know thick enough
atmosphere to utilize aerodynamic flight
like that so you have to do propulsive
Landing for Mars
um you're going to land on an unprepared
surface you know so it has to be able to
do this at some point the ultimate it
sounds ridiculous and it is but the
ultimate goal of it is to land on Mars
there's not much of an atmosphere to
like to help you with the for the belly
fat to be useful there's only one
percent the atmosphere on Mars as there
is on Earth but you still want to
utilize as much of that atmosphere as
possible so in the upper atmosphere it's
still going to be coming in more or less
uh kind of perpendicular to the
Airstream I guess it's probably more
like you know 60 degrees 70 degrees to
the Airstream like where it's belly
flopping and it's gonna especially do
that on Mars it's going to need to you
know use up as let the little bit of
atmosphere there is you know you're
coming in at insane velocities and so
even that one percent thin atmosphere is
still going to do a lot of work now on
Mars there's only 38 of Earth's gravity
on Mars so the belly flop maneuver is a
lot it could be a lot more conservative
you could do that at like 5000 feet up
and it just wouldn't matter as much
because there's not as much gravity loss
or gravity drag so you can kind of just
more more slowly gently you know you
don't have to do this crazy extravagant
like belly flop you know flip maneuver
but it would still something at some
point you would transition from more or
less perpendicular to the Airstream to
you know and horizontal to Landing
vertically I like how we're having this
old boring conversation about the
differences of landing on Earth versus
on Mars
uh this is surreal that this is actually
a real conversation that uh this is
something that we're discussing yeah
because it has to do both yeah
but in my opinion yes I think we'll
pretty quickly see an evolution of
Starship that's like dedicated versions
for certain tasks sure and at the end of
the day again if if it's if someone runs
a simulation says it's actually more
efficient and it's better just to land
horizontally on a Runway then that's
what's gonna happen you know it it
doesn't matter but they still will
develop you know if the ultimate goal is
to land on Mars and they'll have a
dedicated Mars variant you know which
will likely look different than the
earth variant you know and they'll still
probably be launched on the same booster
you know what I mean so there's Oh you
mean like that particular vehicle will
not be returning back to Earth it'll
need to be modified because uh because
the ultimate is to have one Starship to
goes to Mars lands on Mars and takes off
of Mars lands back on Earth and is
reused again yeah over and over and over
and there's a chance that you you know
you have just a cycler just a you know
if you're if you at the end of the day
you're just really trying to see what is
most feasible what's the most efficient
you literally have a vehicle dedicated
to Mars Mars it's easy to do a single
stage to orbit it's a lot lower gravity
a lot thinner atmosphere you can easily
do a single stage orbit you get into
orbit you park to a dedicated you know
transfer vehicle that goes between Earth
and Mars it only stays in space you
don't have heat shields you don't have
Landing Lakes you don't have all these
things that you need and ideally it's
nuclear powered so it's super efficient
that gets you back to earth once you're
at Earth you Rendezvous again with
another Landing Starship and that
Starship might be horizontal Runway
Starship you know like yeah there's no I
I don't see the and I think ultimately
it'll win out where we don't have a one
size fits all I think that's that's the
flaw of the Space Shuttle really is that
it was trying to do everything and I
ended up kind of doing nothing well but
that's I think what SpaceX has proven I
mean SpaceX already has variants coming
there's already going to be a dedicated
lunar lander for NASA for the Artemis
program there's already going to be a
tanker variant there's already going to
be likely just a pure cargo version
there's likely going to be a human
version we'll likely see evolutions of
this thing happen you know relatively
quickly
and one once it's all working it's only
a matter of weeks before people riding
on it will be complaining about the
speed of the Wi-Fi
as the old like uh Lucy K joke with like
where you're flying on a chair through
the air it's incredible you didn't even
know this existed and now you're
complaining about it oh that's great
exactly uh so you yeah you tweeted fun
fact about Starship by doing the flip
around 500 meters versus higher up like
two two thousand meters the difference
in Delta V is 500 meters per second
that's a 20 ton fuel saving which means
basically 20 tons more you can put into
orbit that's more than uh Falcon 9 has
ever launched just by flipping later
that's really interesting so there that
was a decision too to flip close to the
ground yeah yeah be closer to the ground
the better the more again the more the
atmosphere is doing work and uh you know
we get into that video really dives into
like gravity losses and gravity drag the
more time you're spent every every
second that your rocket engine is
running Earth is stealing 9.8 meters per
second of acceleration against you
there's just inherently 9.8 meters per
second squared of acceleration so every
second that engine is running
the first a big majority of your thrust
is actually being just stolen by Earth's
gravity well so if you're the longer
you're fighting that the more
inefficient it is so ID I mean the best
thing would be you flip at you know 100
meters off the ground you light all your
engines to maximum thrust you pull 50
G's you know you land on a dime
basically obviously there's no margin
there there's you know and there's
diminishing returns on that that gravity
loss thing in your high thrust weight
ratios so that's a pretty good
compromise like yes it looks scary but
they could be a lot more aggressive with
that yet and squeeze out even a little
bit better performance but there are
diminishing returns so that's kind of
the magic number we've seen so far today
but we'll likely see that you know be
played with
you've attended uh some of these what
does it feel like to see Starship in
person first of all women is just uh
sitting there stacked and second of all
one is doing some of these tests some of
these maneuvers
well first off if you have the freedom
of traveling and happen to live within a
reasonable
either by plane or car it's worth going
down to South Texas it's so Starbase is
right on the border of Mexico and the
United States and very southern tip of
Texas right along the Rio Grande
and uh it's it's insane because it's
right along a public Highway you can
literally anyone can drive down this
assuming it's not closed for testing
because they do close the highways
during the week a decent amount while
they're doing tests but Sands any of
those days anyone can just drive down
and see these things up close and
personal with their own eyes like we're
talking you know from
100 200 meters away you know so two
football fields away from the world's
biggest most powerful rocket imagine
being able to do that during the you
know Soviet Union and you know during
the N1 and the Saturn V you know imagine
just being able to drive up right next
to the launch pad there's no way you
know and so
to have this kind of access to to this
program is so incredible the craziest
thing is when you when you're driving
out on the on Highway four it's
bumpy it's it's you know riddled with
potholes now because of all the insane
amount of trucks having to go out there
and traffic and you're going through
this it's just this weird you're like
where am I you occasionally you're
seeing like you can kind of see the I
mean you can see Mexico out your right
window as you're driving down this
highway you know you're just sitting
there like where am I and then all of a
sudden you kind of turn this corner and
the trees and the brush kind of clear
out and obviously you get a sense of
everything on the horizon and at that
point you're pretty much five miles on
the nose or eight kilometers away and
from there you can just see through the
the heat Haze through the you know the
atmospheric Distortion and you just see
this weird like it looks like a city
almost on the horizon you know there's
tons of these tall buildings there's a
weird ominous launch Tower thing With
Arms Wide Open and sometimes and you
know a giant metal rocket and it just
looks so so weird I mean it is it's the
word surreal I think by definition I
think if you are expecting it it's not
surreal I think surreal kind of means
like unexpected surprise or whatever you
know even if you're expecting it even if
you've seen pictures even if everything
it is surreal yeah you stand there and
you just go what is this and and also I
mean there is a there's a kind of
magical aspect to the the this is the
place where over the next few years
we'll start
as a human species reaching out there
that's traveling out there we'll for
sure see the development of the rockets
that I think will take us further than
ever before
be born right there what's it like to
witness the actual testing of of
Starship
so far it's been high stakes
like it's it's been insane because those
the the first I kind of mentioned
earlier there's been sn8 9 10 11 and 15
that have all done these suborbital hops
the highest one went 12.5 kilometers in
the rest of the four went 10 kilometers
in altitude and then turned off the
engines and just fell now the cool thing
about that is the general public could
be about five five miles away so again
like eight kilometers away
and the weird thing is this Rocket's
slowly accelerating they didn't want to
exceed a certain speed so they didn't
have to worry about the aerodynamics of
it you know they just slowly climbed and
it probably also to appease the FAA
they're like here we'll just limit the
thrust away ratio and just you know make
make it so it's slow and controlled no
big deal so it's basically more or less
like slightly above a hover just
climbing forever for minutes for like
four or five minutes you just hear and
feel the Roar of this thing normal
Rockets like after the first 30 seconds
or minute you know they're so far away
that you're just diminishing you know
it's just it's just fading fading fading
fading you still get that Rumble that
that sense but but those first five
flights uh the suborbital Hops were just
I'll cherish them forever because you
just you're watching this thing that
you've driven up next to you've seen it
with your own eyes that's bigger than
most buildings in a you know fairly
dense urban area you know it's this
massive thing you stay in the you stood
there you look at it you're like wow
that's crazy you've seen people working
on it they're little ants compared to it
then you drive away and you see it on
the horizon and all of a sudden that
thing leaves it starts moving hovering
hovering essentially and the first time
I mean
you know you put for me at least I put
my hands on my head when I I just I
can't help it I'm not it's not so I
don't know it is like you said
I don't know what in human nature
decides this is what to do when you
can't believe something but that's what
happens and when that thing first took
off it was just like my brain couldn't
process
seeing you know because I had spent so
much time driving around and seeing it
and all of a sudden you're watching it
just take off and you're like it's
moving and all these you know the most
complicated rocket engines ever made are
all firing simultaneously and it didn't
blow up on the launch pad and slowly
increasing
and it's just crazy and the sound the
everything about it and so by the time
the first one is specifically it was it
was December 2020 was the first uh sn8
it went up and I actually we all lost it
in the sky we couldn't quite see it but
our we had telescopes and and you know
hide telephoto lenses tracking it and
what's funny is there's a pretty strong
wind up there at altitude
and it was moving there's a lot of um
gaseous oxygen being vented out of the
rocket and it's you know being blown by
this air so it looks like it's moving
actually quite quickly like away from us
like a strafing to one side so I'm
watching the monitor I'm going oh my God
they're moving it like over Brownsville
and we're all all of us everyone on this
this hotel balcony is looking out down
like way out over you know and we can't
find it we're like where did they lose
it like we're thinking like oh my God
this is gonna crash down in Brownsville
and and finally they shut the engines
off and were watching it fall and again
we're tracking it we know it's falling
and it's falling falling it's falling
super controlled and we're like oh my
God this is perfect
and all of a sudden it clicked and I see
it with my you know my eyes I finally
like track and it's it's straight out
like straight in front of us and it
looks like it looks like it was a blimp
just barely moving now because it is
Falling Slowly thanks to all of its drag
and again that's one of those moments
I'm like it's falling so slow you know
because it's so big it's so massive it's
falling sideways you know I've seen
Falcon 9 boosters and Falcon heavy
boosters and they scream they come in so
fast and you can barely even see we can
just barely check them obviously light
their engines and they they decelerate
so quickly this was like the opposite it
was like
is that thing ever coming down it was
just falling so slowly and so right
there just felt like it was so close and
so when it finally lit its engine and it
flipped I was losing my mind because I'm
like it's working you know this crazy
plan this huge massive thing is doing
this absurd feat and the first one well
the first four again didn't work out as
planned but getting to that point
already getting to that flip maneuver
was a huge milestone and it was so
exciting just going through those those
firsts were amazing and I think you know
we're coming up now on them doing the
full stacks of the booster and the upper
stage
I think when we see that fly when that
leaves Earth for the first time it'll be
like I said almost twice the amount of
thrust as anything else it'll be the
biggest heaviest largest thing to ever
fly it's going to shake everything I
can't wait to have all 33 Raptor engines
uh been active at once have they tested
that no that's coming up that's kind of
the next Milestone um I don't know you
know when this will come out but we're
that's like the next just a few days
very quickly here it then but if people
listen to this if they're listening to
it early on they'll likely be able to
catch you know I think at this point it
seems like next week so step one would
be static fire yep holding onto the
rocket and lighting up the engines and
so so far they've lit at most they kind
of they went for like a more than 14
engine static fired I don't recall if it
was like you know 16 or something
engines lit at once and they ended up
going down to 14 engines that's the most
engines they've ever lit
um so the next step and the final kind
of Step before they they fly this thing
is they're actually going to light all
33 engines simultaneously and although
that sounds scary let's not forget the
Falcon heavy that's now flown five times
completely flawlessly
um has has 27 engines running
simultaneously so they definitely have
you know SpaceX has experience with high
number of engines running at the same
time but it is still like this is going
to be a lot of moving parts and a lot of
potential and a lot just a lot of
everything uh what are the upcoming
uh Milestones expected milestones and I
think um there's one in particular I'd
like to talk to you more about but
leading up to that of course is like
what what are some of the tests here on
the way so this is the static fire uh
the the fully stacked with the two
stages
uh will there be uh and then all that
leading to an orbital
launch test uh what so what other things
we should know about and what do you
think like what what do you think the
timeline would be with like the orbital
test timeline uh the reason we have this
website the expected Milestones is
because I always tell people to ignore
any time you ever hear for any of this
stuff yeah just pay attention to
Milestones because when you're doing
stuff for the first time you know you
just have no idea so just to understand
the expected Milestones here the First
Column is the event the the second
columns the date and Status TBD complete
green means what green means it's been
completed and it shows the completion
date there and the completion date yeah
and then the others maybe maybe more
maybe not if the full full stack testing
the d-stack and the there's a 33 engine
so so realistically we're expecting them
to de-stack and SpaceX I think just
tweeted that actually they're going to
be de-stacking
um the second stage from the first stage
kind of get the ship safe while they
test because they don't want to you know
33 engines is pretty high risk if they
do blow up the rocket when they test it
for the first time it's not going to be
fully fueled I don't think at least but
there is a limit to how they do have to
have it weighed down enough that the
launch clamps can hold on to it because
if you think about it like normally the
launch clamps are holding on to an
entire rocket weighing 5 million
kilograms 5 million I get you know it's
weighing at an insane amount so those
clamps don't actually have to hold 75
Mega Newtons of thrust they really want
to have to hold down 25 Mega Newtons of
thrust you know what I mean they're not
designed to hold down all 75. so they do
have to have enough weight on the rocket
so that so even when they do these the
testing of the 33 engines it'll have to
have enough propellant in there that
they don't exceed the clamping and the
holding force of the stand otherwise
it'll break free from the launch stand
and that booster will go flying off
uncontrolled so it's a difficult thing
to figure out in the test how many uh
simultaneous things you test right so
they're kind of mitigating risks which
is why like they're d-stack you know
they don't want to have although the
ship could be on top of it to help weigh
it down and simulate the you know the
launch environment better at some point
that's a risk they're just going to take
when they go for launch and so for now
they're taking the ship off in case
something goes wrong during the 33
engine test and then once we see if the
33 engine test goes well hopefully we
see the the second stage get stacked
back on it we'll see him get closer like
closing out all the items and hope the
big one too is the FAA launch license
there that's a that'll be publicly filed
we'll see that you know in the system uh
having a launch license and I I have no
sense in that type of thing you know
that's outside of but that's but that is
a big milestone and it might be
something that could potentially hinder
uh you know hold up the launch date
would just be waiting for a launch
license
yeah I'm sure there's a lot of
fascinating bureaucracy and politics and
uh
legal stuff and all that kind of
beautiful magical thing when you live in
reality because it is I mean it is a big
uh rocket yeah one the biggest thing
it's not so much the fa doesn't
necessarily care about the success of
the rocket they just really just care
about the safety of public and public
property you know so it's it's it's a
matter of being convinced and having the
the data to prove okay if this thing
blows up we have a control of how and
when it blows up we have control of you
know X Y and Z here's the potential
damage here's the blast radius you know
this again is over twice as powerful and
twice as much potential actually it's a
lot more potential for an explosive
energy if it you know where it happened
to well let me walk back a little
because in order to have a real
detonation you have to have a perfect
mixture ratio of your fuel and oxidizer
um if when a rocket blows up typically
you know it kind of unzips and some of
the fuel will mix into some of the
oxidizer and you could have some
explosive energy but a lot of it's
actually just a deflagration it's just
you know flames and and yeah there will
there would be explosive energy but it's
not like you're lighting all of it
simultaneously it's this giant bomb it's
just really not so that's good but at
the same time even in those
circumstances the amount of energy is
still absurd enough to likely blow out
windows you know for miles and miles and
miles including my studio space
uh well if the cameras hold up it would
be one heck of a show uh hopefully of
course would not uh would not happen so
how does that take us to an orbital
launch when do you think that would
happen
in in my opinion uh this is a very fluid
and this will change literally by the
hour so you really think that it's very
difficult to really say like even even
for something that could very well
happen this year even just a few months
away
um making a prediction uh by the way you
like superstitious on this kind of stuff
a little bit like you don't you're
worried about jinxing it and that kind
of stuff no
um because I would imagine you would be
like waiting for all of these launches
that keep getting delayed or you start
thinking that there's certain things you
do will control the weather my socks if
I'm wearing these socks I just scrubbed
again you know like yeah you're lucky
you have to wear the same lucky socks
otherwise it's going to there's going to
be bad weather yeah so the reason that I
say this and why it's so difficult is
they did a first full stack test in July
of 2021 and the expectation was we're a
month or two away from a launch yeah so
like realistically for 18 months I've
been in a Purgatory thinking that we're
a month or two away of an orbital launch
now I did say for the record third when
that thing stacked and when a lot of
speculation was saying you know a month
or two I was saying I don't expect it to
fly in 2021. you know and I've been just
say I just saw the amount of work that
still needed to be done like on the
ground systems the tanks the the launch
Mount all the stuff I'm sitting there
like there's still a lot of stuff
they're gonna have to validate it
they're gonna have to test everything
every component and you know people were
like how dare you say that even Gwen
Shotwell the president of SpaceX is
saying Q3 of 2021 I'm like okay but like
I'm just I'm not going to be surprised
if it slips into 2022. and here we are
the beginning of 2023 and I I think
we're finally within like two months
I I'm expecting like I'm trying to keep
my March in April as free as I can
we'll put it that way